hey guys dr. Burke here in this video
we're gonna talk about the real cause of
prostate enlargement there is a lot of
false information floating around out
there that states that this condition is
coming from too much DHT which is a very
powerful form of testosterone now if
that was true then why is it that this
hormone is given to men with enlarged
prostates to shrink it it's used as a
therapy so that can't be the real cause
in fact as you age especially when you
hit 50 this hormone and this hormone
decreases so how could it be that all of
a sudden at 50-year prostate starts
enlarging because the true cause of a
prostate enlargement is the combination
of ratio of low testosterone in high
estrogen because in a male body
what does increase when they when they
get into the 40s and 50s and 60s is
estrogen that's really what's causing an
enlarged prostate one of the big causes
of increased estrogen is not only the
hormones in the food supply but it's
also drinking alcohol so alcohol is
notorious for increasing estrogen in the
body giving male about his breast tissue
you lose your hair on the the calf's
your voice starts going high here but
the prostate starts enlarging okay so
the couple of things you can do to undo
this and reverse this number one you can
not drink alcohol number one okay that's
a good idea number two you can start
consuming more cruciferous vegetables
especially other vegetables like beets
would be good beet tops would be good if
you mix it with kale put it in a blender
with maybe a little bit of a cup of
frozen berries and blend it with water
that would be very good but the other
two herbs that I always recommend you
can pretty much get them anywhere is
nettle root and saw palmetto
nevel route is awesome for helping lower
estrogen and increasing testosterone and
it's also good for inflammation anywhere
in the body it works like that and then
also adding this one as well it's a
great combination to help help you so go
ahead and try this and put your comments
below I hope this helps
hey guys thank you so much for watching
I really appreciate it please click the
share button below and I will see you in
the next video